hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deaths life now I know I
said that I was gonna have reading your
comments today but things have just been
incredibly busy and I want to take my
time with those videos because they're
always important to me and they're
always important that they come across
like I put a lot of effort into him so I
want to do want to have time and
everyone should be out of the house by
Thursday but I'm gonna try to do it
tonight but if I can't then it's
probably just gonna come next week and
I'm really sorry for that I wouldn't do
it if I didn't have absolutely no time
at all but either way Oh a new deaths
recruits welcome I'm going to teach you
the basic of deaths flow I was like some
final destination [ __ ] here your goal is
to cause the death of the character
that's morbid for this you must create a
chain reaction rearranging the objects
in the scene hover over the objects to
identify what can be rearranged and
click on them to distrain its position
okay now identify which object initiates
the reaction highlighted in blue I don't
see a highlight in blue oh okay growl
then interesting fancy that finally take
your time and arrange the objects as
good as you can when satisfied click on
the object that initiates a reaction and
carefully observe what happens
you failed Oh God not good I didn't even
know what I did okay so I failed but
this okay so there was a chain riad okay
so there's a chain reaction starting
with that object so I gotta amend
navigate all of these such that they're
moved there we go
okay I think I got everything
pink slam that gets knocked dammit I got
[ __ ] I got this though and ah oh ah oh
[ __ ] that's not what I wanted
okay so they all got to be in the right
positions so I just have to kind of go
with the flow of it to make sure that
it's all hunky-dory let's try this one
uh-huh go yeah yeah I like it I like it
like it a lot
come on in yeah oh you're sad looking oh
that's no good huh how did you survive
what can a good idea was it to jump into
them oh my god well alright then that
works out better in my favorite than I
thought it's kind of a strange turn of
events and he would jump straight into
the puddle that he obviously was gonna
slip on hey I did it I got animate
objects hooray okay so this is the
object in blue so that's gonna do
something that drips there I don't know
which one that is how am I supposed to
know which one's gonna do with all right
beer amine ah this here that there this
that this and then absolutely nothing
else
boink oh god okay
damnit ok so that was the right that was
the wrong way that needs to be flipped
over there this needs to be do that then
it needs to be do that this goes here
that goes there this goes there and then
we're good
this is finicky ten hard to tell exactly
what something's gonna do bang flippity
doo dah
[ __ ] I don't know if that okay I got it
we're gonna sign it okay that drips into
that thing the red thing goes Brown
putting an explosion that's totally
awesome but probably gonna lead to
someone's murder that's gonna go off
blasts out there hit that knock over on
that that did absolutely nothing holy
[ __ ] I'm dumb five of six objects though
so I'm pretty close come on
okay that goes there that goes there oh
my god the bunny's gone rabid be careful
whoever's gonna walk into this situation
oh no oh that ain't good
why would you why would you do that why
why is that just a bun Oh God oh my god
heads always have to come off oh the
bunny what could a weird-ass thing it
would just be like the chemicals would
be just grow high under there you're
gonna have a bad time okay so that the
traffic gonna start the chain reaction
alright I don't know look good was that
gonna do okay so if that's there that's
gonna knock that that's such a slight
difference how am I supposed to be able
to predict anything about that alright
this is guess it's guessing right here
donk thunk okay that did not do that all
right
this [ __ ] let's try some of this yeah
[ __ ] damn it okay oink oink oink oink
try that try some of that it's that that
goes there that knocks over it did do
nothing there because that was not
supposed to be moved yeah okay so that
stays there this goes here that goes
there this goes there this turns this
turns turns bang boom bottom death
approaches that [ __ ]
okay so it was just a one object that
was out of place that hits that that his
eye that goes there Blanc
thunk yes did his head pop off that's my
only concern the only objective of this
entire game is to make sure that they
get decapitated before the end of it I
mean it didn't fall that hard down on
them I'm gonna operate under the
assumption though that's the end of the
demo just three measly levels and you
got markiplier cheering for decapitation
that's what this game does to you okay
so that's all the time I got for now I
have guests that I need to entertain
unfortunately I'm sorry that reading
your comments got so delayed this game
is really fun though it is just a demo
and I believe that the game is coming
out on Steam it's trying to get greenlit
on Steam very interesting concept I bet
there's a few more things that you could
do in terms of making it more active and
engaging in the planning out process and
giving it a few more clues as to what
things can do and also leading to other
scenarios where things end up in not a
way that you expected so there's some
work that could be done but it's a
really cool concept so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
again for the patience
I'll be back in working order very soon
it's just been a hectic week so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video